[Music]  what is corpus linguistics and or are  some definitions and examples of corpus  linguistics and studies corpus  linguistics is the study of language  based on large collections of a  real-life language use stored in corpora  or corpuses computerized databases  created for linguistic research also  known as corpus based studies corpus  linguistics is viewed by some linguists  as a research tool or methodology and by  others as a discipline or theory in its  own right Kubla and since meister  conclude that the answer to the question  whether corpus linguistics is a theory  or a tool is simply that it can be both  it depends on how corpus linguistics is  applied  if this video was informative than like  subscribe and comment below in the  section if you have any questions or  anything to add